we mentioned a few paid options and
finished up the paid marketing portion
of the lesson with some of the basics of
paid social media marketing channels
however social media is integrated so
well into our lives that there are many
ways to leverage social media for your
business for free the idea is your
social platforms to encourage people to
spread the word about your app within
their circles the first step in doing
this is to engage a community online
using social platforms this is where
we're going to start talking about free
marketing methods for your business
after you talk about the free social
communities to help with customer
acquisition we're going to look into
inbound marketing